all right one last point about a team
that has very low expectations although
their first overall pick kyler murray
high expectations because he's drawing
comparisons to patrick mahomes
cliff kingsbury the coach of the
cardinals recently addressed the
question of whether or not the cardinals
will use shotgun formation exclusively
or close to it in 2019 and it sure looks
like that's what they're going to do
chris from a football standpoint because
kingsbury said it really doesn't matter
there's no disadvantage from not
snapping under center and the advantage
is you don't have to worry about backing
out from under center you don't have to
worry about trying to pick up the
defense you're already there you can
already see everything before the snap
after the snap you're already in
position and maybe that's even more
useful for a shorter quarterback but do
is there a disadvantage to always going
shotgun formation other than the
ever-present possibility the ball is
going to get snapped over the guy's head
no i do think there's disadvantages
there yeah i do i mean there's a reason
that the new england patriots and tom
brady get underneath the center and have
a full back and a tail back behind them
and they're coming downhill to run the
football when you're in the shotgun the
running backs first step could not be
downhill it has to be horizontal to
first get the ball and if okay maybe
he's in the pistol yeah okay yeah he
could be behind him and you give him the
ball that way but i think the two things
is here that you know jump out to me you
know what you lose is that downhill
aspect of the running game to a degree
the play-action pass game would be the
other thing that i worry about and i
think that could be a good tool for kylo
murray because play action passes you
can get the quarterback really deep
behind the line of scrimmage to where it
creates a lot of space to where he'll be
able to see
a lot more clearly than maybe people
would realize but i'm not shocked cliff
kingsbury has shown nothing uh of ever
being a shotgun type coach that's where
kyler murray is uh of course the most
comfortable and you want him to start
out at least in a comfortable position
and maybe cliff kingsbury's offense
grows into that eventually
yeah and play action passing and this is
one thing i think i heard ron jaworski
explain it once and it really resonated
for me that challenge of because if
you're in shotgun you're it's like it's
like playing a video game yeah you're
there you see the defense before the
snap you see the defense at the snap all
you have to do is look away for a split
second to catch the ball and sometimes
you don't even look away you see it out
of your peripheral vision when you do
play action you're looking at the
defense and then you completely turn
your back on the defense for the amount
of time that it takes to turn pretend
you're handing it off and then turn back
and a lot of stuff can happen during
that period of time that you have turned
away from the defense so you have to
reacquaint you have to recalibrate it is
a very difficult skill for quarterbacks
to muster but a lot of times it leads to
the biggest completions and some of the
easiest looks you'll see because of the
things you just mentioned you know your
spot though think about what you just
said but if you're the linebacker that's
playing the run right you're going oh
wait the quarterback's turned his back
it really looks like he's going to give
the ball to the running back the running
back's coming downhill at a very fast
rate whoa i better get him be in my gap
and stop this run wait wait oh oh oh
gosh who's got the ball oh no the
quarterback's got the ball i got to turn
around and run oh man there goes julian
edelman over the middle for a 25-yard
gain you know that's the beauty of play
action it's a great way you know to
get explosive plays in the nfl and
really mess with the second line of
defense the down safety the middle
linebackers that takes aggressive nature
away from those guys on the football
field that's where i think ultimately
you know i'd hope cliff kingsbury does
get some underneath the center type of
plays for kyle murray because i think he
could be very dangerous in that setting
in a roundabout way it's the original
rpo although there is no there is no
option you know that you're not going to
hand the ball off but you are selling it
even more effectively than they do in
the rpi exactly yeah if you're if your
running game is potent that's the best
way to use it you gash them four yards
five yards six yards four yards seven
yards and and they they get to the point
where we had enough of this crap we're
here we go we're gonna go get this guy
and you're completely out of position
right for the fake and it's just like
it's a cat and mouse game at that point
exactly and you you lose all that when
you're in shotgun all the time and
there's no way to simulate it in shotgun
i guess that's the reason i think that's
it you can't get
the high end of play action passing when
it's clicking you can't do that in
shotgun yeah
that's exactly right mike and yeah you
know you can get some play action pass
but again like you said when you're
playing quarterback it's like a video
game well when the quarterback's in
shotgun it's also like a video game for
the middle linebacker so they can see
the picture and the quarterback that
much more clearly and see was the ball
actually given to the running back and
all those things so uh again i know that
kyler murray and cliff kingsbury can
make it work but hey play action pass
running the ball down the hill the
saints the rams the new england patriots
the eagles they all do it they all have
effective play-action pass games just
think of that patriots chargers
divisional playoff game right mike you
know the pay the patriots were just
gashing like you said against the
chargers four yards five yards four
yards five yards and all of a sudden he
brady keeps the ball and julian
edelman's wide open down the middle of
the field for a 25-yard gain that's the
beauty of it uh but i think the
cardinals will be just fine and you want
to keep your rookie star quarterback
comfortable at least early on in this in
this process
who is the all-time best quarterback at
pulling off the play-action fake oh gosh
i mean peyton manning was phenomenal um
i'll tell you boomer osiason
was an incredible play-action uh pass
quarterback uh i'm missing some other
ones
um chad pennington was really good
no doubt great call by you mike without
a doubt those are guys who really got
into the craft of i'm going to make my
run plays look exactly like the
play-action pass games and that can mess
with the defense
hey i saw the chiefs and the steelers
1989 in pittsburgh and de berg was the
quarterback of the chiefs and i can't
tell you how many times i was where's
the ball yeah right right i have no idea
where the ball is right now and uh de
berg the master of he was de berg sneaky
great career in the nfl almost like a
ryan fitzpatrick we talk about
fitzpatrick day just a guy who continues
to hang around and hang around and
meanwhile racking up big statistics and
having a quietly very excellent career
but he was the master of that play
action phase
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports